Speaker 1: Now, as I mentioned, Joe Manchin, of
course, is public enemy number one right now.
But at the same time, we also
have to remember that there's also
50 Republicans in that Senate body in all 50 of
those Republicans, including those moderates,
moderates in quotes there. All 50 of them
are against this piece of legislation, too,
so let's take just a moment and give
them the credit that they are due,
because after all, let's be real honest here. The
media, including those of us in progressive media,
we have focused a lot of energy this year on
Mansion Cinema Tester, but really, we also have
to give some of that blame to all 50 Republicans
in the Senate. Because not a single one of them,
not Murkowski, not Collins, not Romney, not
those sensible, reasonable, moderate Republicans.
None of them support this thing, either.
And at this point, all it would take is one.
Literally one, because if we don't have Joe
Manchin assuming we do have cinema and the other
moderate Dems, if we got one Republican,
okay, problem solved. Problem solved.
But we can't even get one. And that also
needs to be a bigger talking point, too,
because Manchin has many years before he is up for
reelection. And I promise you, by then the public
will have forgotten about this. That's the way
the news cycle goes. As the old saying goes, the
public doesn't have a memory passed last Tuesday.
Cinema, on the other hand, is facing a reelection
fairly soon. And things are not looking
good for her, according to the polls.
But we have to make this a campaign issue
for the Republicans as well, and that,
of course, lies with the Democratic Party. Because
everybody's been focusing on the Democrats there.
They also have to re shift some of the
blame and put it back on these Republicans.
We're all well aware of Joe Manchin's role
in all of this. And of course, by the way,
Manchin, the White House, have said, Hey, talks
aren't over yet. We're going to keep talking about
this. So as I actually pointed out yesterday
on the show, when Manchin said on Fox News,
I can't support this bill, it likely means this
incarnation of the bill. But all those Republicans
are against it, it wouldn't matter if you cut it
down to giving every American a single dollar.
Every one of those Republicans would vote against
it because they know that build back better.
Even in its scaled down form. Would still be a
huge benefit to the American public and therefore
a huge victory for Democrats to ride into the
midterms. So we have to dispel with the myth
that there are moderate Republicans out there.
And that's what Democrats need to attack.
We've heard all the stories about the
Republican infighting, you know, oh,
Trump's going after McConnell, you've got members
of the House going after members of the Senate.
There's fighting, they can't agree on
anything, but no, at the end of the day,
they always come together to do what's
not best for the American public.
And the Democrats have to hammer on
that Republicans have 20 Senate seats
up for reelection in the year 2022, so less than
12 months away, 20 of those Republicans have to
defend those seats. It's going to cost them a
lot of money to do this. It's very difficult
for a party to not only retain every single one
of their seats when they have more seats up,
but also to win new ones. So Democrats have a
shot at making some inroads in the Senate here.
Of course, it's going to be hard when they
don't have the thing to deliver to the public,
so what you deliver instead? Is the talking
point that we would have this? If you had
one decent Republican in that Senate
body, because right now we don't.
It doesn't matter if you're an extremist, if
you're a hardcore corporatist like Mitch McConnell
or if you're the seemingly sweet, nice guy,
moderate and Mitch, not Mitch, Mitt Romney.
They're all the same at the end of the day.
They're all fighting against this agenda for
political reasons only. And if the Democrats
can hammer on that, if the Democrats can make
that the talking point, if they can kind
of shift some focus away from Joe Manchin,
who again, I still agree he is the biggest
villain in all of this. If it weren't for him,
we wouldn't be having this conversation.
But we cannot let these 50 Republicans
get away without any of the blame.
Because all it would take is one.
But we can't even get that to happen. I'm Farron
Cousins, follow me on Twitter YouTube. Instagram,
Facebook at Faron Balanced and of course, the
big YouTube channel youtube.com slash the ring
of fire, and if that's not enough for you, I also
host the weekly Ring of Fire podcast. Just go to
our O.f podcast dot com to sign up. I'm sitting in
for David Pakman. We'll be right back with more.